[Music]
what is web3
there's a lot of buzz surrounding web3
but really what is it honestly it took
me well to wrap my head around it
because
people make it seem like it's so
complicated but at the heart of it not
really
web3 is not a platform or a type of
technology or something you're going to
find in the metaverse it's actually more
like an era or a categorization but
before we dive deeper into this know
that all this categorization is still
pretty vague because there isn't some
official body out there saying hey this
is web3 the way people can say hey it's
2022. long story short web3 wants to be
a decentralized internet in web 3 people
wanted to take a step back from the web
2 structure where power rested in the
hands of a few tech ceos at the
foundation of web 3 is the development
of blockchain now blockchain is a
technology behind cryptocurrencies and
at its core decentralized so how does
blockchain decentralize the internet
usually when talking about blockchain
you hear it associated with bitcoin and
other kinds of cryptocurrencies but but
this is because for example bitcoin
isn't maintained by just one company but
by a vast network of computers all
connected to the internet
[Music]
now that we know how web 3 can exist the
question is why are venture capitals
throwing billions of dollars into web 3.
a chunk of that money is going into the
development of gaps or d apps still
debated on how that said dabs
dapps or decentralized apps are one of
the reasons why you're seeing so much
optimism around web 3. here's my
colleague zupinghuang with more on the
apps thanks nico so dabs run on top of
blockchains like ethereum or solana
instead of servers run by big companies
like facebook that means no one can
actually shut them down
but what's more important is that depth
users can have the full ownership of
their data tokens or virtual assets for
real
some of the most popular applications
are in finance and gaming for example
this app called pancake swap allows you
to trade one coin for another without
any middleman matching orders and
there's a head game called axi infinity
it's just like pokemon but you can sell
your virtual pads for money
at the same time web3 also has its
skeptics elon musk said it seemed like a
marketing buzzword back in december
cryptographer and signal app founder
moxie marlin spike also discussed the
issue of servers in a post discussing
web3
unless people start running their own
servers and very few people and even
organizations do this it's not really
decentralized accountability could also
be a big issue with web3 regulators are
raising concerns with some issues
regarding decentralized finance or defy
apps that let people land borrow and
trade points with each other they do so
without verifying users identities and
performing anti-money logger and
background checks finally there's
environmental concerns about the huge
amount of computing power some
blockchains require
at the end of the day we have to ask is
web3 really worth the hype or is it just
a bunch of tech talk celebrated by a
niche market let us know what you guys
think
you